Pat Mitchell: Ese día,
8 de enero de 2011, comenzó como cualquier otro.
Estaban ambos trabajando en lo que les apasiona.
Tú estabas con tus partidarios,
que es algo que te encantaba hacer
cuando eras congresista,
y Mark, tú estabas felizmente preparándote
para tu próximo transbordador espacial.
Y de repente, todo lo que habían planeado,
o esperado de sus vidas,
cambió irremediablemente para siempre.
Mark Kelly: Sí, es increíble,
es increíble cómo todo puede cambiar
para cualquiera de nosotros en un instante.
La gente no se da cuenta.
Yo ciertamente no lo vi.
Gabby Giffords: Sí.
MK: Y en la mañana de ese sábado,
recibí esa horrible llamada
de la jefe de gabinete de Gabby.
Ella no tenía mucha más información.
Solo me dijo: "Le dispararon a Gabby".
Unos minutos después, la llamé yo
y pensé por un instante,
a lo mejor me imaginé esa llamada.
La llamé y fue entonces cuando me dijo
que a Gabby le habían disparado en la cabeza.
Y a partir de ese momento,
supe que nuestras vidas iban a ser muy diferentes.
PM: Y cuando llegaste al hospital,
¿cuál fue el pronóstico que te dieron
del estado clínico de Gabby y qué recuperación, si la hubiese,
podías esperar?
MK: Bueno, con una herida de bala en la cabeza
y una lesión cerebral traumática
normalmente no te pueden decir mucho.
Cada lesión es diferente. No se puede predecir,
como a menudo se puede con un derrame cerebral
que es otro tipo de lesión cerebral.
Así que no sabían cuánto tiempo Gabby estaría en coma,
ni cuándo eso cambiaría
ni cuál sería el pronóstico.
PM: Gabby, tu recuperación
¿ha sido un esfuerzo para crear una nueva Gabby Giffords
o para recuperar a la antigua Gabby Giffords?
GG: La nueva; mejor, más fuerte, más dura.
(Aplausos)
MK: Es decir,
cuando miras nuestra foto atrás,
volver de ese tipo de lesión
y volver fuerte, más fuerte que nunca
es algo muy difícil de lograr.
No conozco a nadie
tan fuerte como mi maravillosa esposa.
(Aplausos)
PM: ¿Y cuáles fueron las primeras señales
de que la recuperación no solo iba a ser posible
sino que se iba a parecer
a la vida que tú y Gabby habían planeado?
MK: Bueno, lo primero para mí,
fue que Gabby todavía estaba medio inconsciente,
pero hizo algo, cuando estaba en cuidados intensivos,
algo que solía hacer cuando
salíamos a cenar a un restaurante:
me sacó el anillo
y lo pasó de un dedo a otro.
En ese momento supe
que ella todavía estaba ahí.
PM: También hubo ciertas palabras.
¿No te sorprendió con lo que dijo al principio?
MK: Bueno, al principio fue duro. GG: ¿Qué? ¿Qué? Pollo. Pollo. Pollo.
MK: Sí, eso era todo.
Durante el primer mes, hasta ahí llegaba
todo el vocabulario de Gabby.
Por alguna razón, tiene afasia,
que dificulta la comunicación.
Se aferró a la palabra "pollo",
que no es la mejor, pero desde luego, tampoco es la peor.
(Risas)
Y de hecho estábamos preocupados
de que pudiera ser mucho peor.
PM: Gabby, ¿cuál ha sido tu mayor desafío
durante esta recuperación?
GG: Hablar. Muy difícil. De verdad.
MK: Sí, con afasia, Gabby sabe lo que quiere decir,
pero no lo puede expresar.
Ella entiende todo,
pero la comunicación es muy difícil.
Porque cuando miras la foto...
La parte del cerebro donde están los centros de comunicación
queda del lado izquierdo de la cabeza,
que es por donde pasó la bala.
PM: Así que tienes que hacer una cosa muy peligrosa:
hablar en nombre de tu esposa.
MK: Lo hago.
Puede ser una de las cosas más peligrosas que he hecho.
PM: Gabby, ¿te sientes optimista
con respecto a tu continua recuperación;
caminar, hablar,
llegar a mover tu brazo y tu pierna?
GG: Soy optimista. Va a ser un camino largo y difícil,
pero soy optimista.
PM: Esa parece ser la característica número uno de Gabby Giffords,
¿no les parece? (Aplausos)
MK: Gabby siempre ha sido muy optimista.
Trabaja muy duro cada día.
GG: En la trotadora, en la banda de correr,
lecciones de español, corno francés.
MK: Sólo mi esposa podría...
Si la hubieran conocido antes de la lesión,
entenderían más o menos esto.
Alguien que puede ser lesionado
con tantas dificultades para comunicarse,
trabaja con un terapeuta de lenguaje,
y hace un mes, ella me dice,
"quiero aprender español de nuevo".
PM: Bueno, echemos un vistazo de cerca
a esta esposa, incluso antes
de que conocieras a Gabby Giffords.
Ahí está en una motoneta.
Tengo entendido que esa es una imagen muy común
de cómo era Gabby Giffords cuando estaba creciendo.
MK: Sí, Gabby solía competir en motocicleta.
Esa es una motoneta, pero ella tenía...
bueno, todavía tiene una motocicleta BMW.
PM: ¿Ella la conduce? MK: Bueno, es un desafío
ya que no puede mover su brazo derecho,
pero pienso que con algo que yo conozco, el velcro,
quizás podamos volver a ponerla sobre la moto,
sujetando su mano derecha al manubrio con velcro.
PM: Tengo la sensación que esa será la siguiente foto,
Gabby.
Pero sabes... ya has decidido
que dedicarás tu vida al servicio.
Comenzarás haciéndote militar
y acabarás convirtiéndote en astronauta.
Así se conocieron.
¿Qué te atrajo de Gabby?
MK: Bueno, cuando nos conocimos, curiosamente...
Fue la última vez que estuvimos en Vancouver,
hace unos 10 años. Allá nos conocimos,
en el aeropuerto, en un viaje que los dos tomamos
a China,
que yo, con mis orígenes,
llamaría un despilfarro.
Gabby diría... GG: Misión de investigación.
MK: Ella diría que fue una importante misión de investigación.
Ella era senadora del Estado en esa época,
y nos conocimos aquí, en el aeropuerto,
antes de viajar a China.
PM: ¿Lo describirías como un romance tempestuoso?
GG: No, no, no.
(Risas)
Un buen amigo.
MK: Si, fuimos amigos por bastante tiempo.
GG: Si. (Risas)
MK: Y entonces me invitó, más o menos un año después,
me invitó a salir.
¿A dónde fuimos, Gabby?
GG: Al corredor de la muerte.
MK: Si. Nuestra primera cita fue en el corredor de la muerte
en la prisión estatal de Arizona en Florence,
justo en las afueras del distrito senatorial del Estado, de Gabby.
Estaban trabajando en cierta legislación
que tenía que ver con el crimen y el castigo
y la pena capital en el Estado de Arizona.
Es que ella no encontraba a nadie que la acompañara,
y yo le dije, "Por supuesto que quiero ir al corredor de la muerte".
Así que esa fue nuestra primera cita.
Desde entonces estamos juntos . GG: Sí.
PM: Bueno, eso pudo haber sido parte de la razón
por la que Gabby decidió casarse contigo.
Estabas dispuesto a ir al corredor de la muerte, después de todo.
MK: Supongo que sí.
PM: Gabby, ¿Que te hizo querer casarte con Mark?
GG: Eh, buenos amigos. Mejores amigos. Los mejores amigos.
MK: Siempre pensé que
teníamos una relación muy especial.
Hemos atravezado tiempos muy difíciles
y solo nos ha unido más. GG: Más fuerte.
PM: Sin embargo, después de casarse
seguían teniendo vidas muy independientes.
De hecho, ni siquiera vivían juntos.
MK: Era uno de esos matrimonios a distancia.
En nuestro caso era Washington D.C., Houston,
Tucson.
A veces en el sentido del reloj,
a veces en el sentido contrario,
a todos esos lugares.
No vivíamos juntos
hasta ese sábado en la mañana.
Menos de una hora después de que le dispararan,
yo iba en un avión a Tucson,
y ese fue el momento
en que cambiaron las cosas.
PM: Y tú, Gabby, habías sido elegida congresista
después de haber sido senadora estatal
y habías trabajaado en el Congreso durante 6 años.
¿Qué es lo que más te gustaba
de estar en el Congreso?
GG: Ritmo rápido. Ritmo rápido.
PM: Bueno,así lo hacías tu. GG: Sí, sí. A ritmo rápido.
PM: No estoy segura de que todos lo describirían de esa manera.
(Risas)
MK: Sí. Se sabe que la legislación normalmente
va a un ritmo lentísimo,
pero mi esposa, tengo que admitirlo,
y muchos otros miembros del Congreso que conozco,
trabajan sumamente duro.
Gabby corría de un lado a otro como loca.
Nunca tomaba un día libre,
tal vez medio día al mes.
En todo momento estaba trabajando.
De verdad que así prosperaba,
y todavía es así, hoy en día. GG: Sí. Sí.
PM: Ahí está instalando paneles solares en el tejado,
tengo que decirlo.
Así que después del trágico accidente, Mark,
decidiste dimitir
de tu posición como astronauta,
a pesar de que normalmente habrías
estado en la siguiene misión espacial.
Todo el mundo, incluso Gabby,
intentó convencerte de que volvieras,
y al final aceptaste.
MK: Más o menos. Al día siguiente de la lesión de Gabby,
llamé a mi jefe, la jefe de los astronautas,
la Dra. Peggy Whitson, y le dije,
"Peggy, sé que tengo que ir al espacio
en tres meses.
Gabby está en coma. Estoy en Tucson.
Tienes que encontrarme un reemplazo".
En realidad no renuncié a ser astronauta,
pero decliné ese trabajo y encontraron un sustituto.
Meses más tarde, tal vez dos meses después,
empecé a pensar en recuperar mi trabajo,
que es algo...
Cuando lo que haces es cuidar a alguien...
Algunas personas en la audiencia
habrán estado en esa situación...
Es un rol desafíante. Pero llega un momento
en el que hay que decidir si vas a recuperar tu vida.
En ese momento, no podía preguntarle a Gabby
si quería que volviese al transbordador espacial.
Pero sabía cómo es ella. GG: Si. Si. Si.
MK: Ella era el apoyo principal de mi carrera,
y sabía que eso era lo correcto.
PM: Aún hoy, intento imaginar, Mark,
cómo es eso de irse en una misión,
que puede parecer segura, pero nunca está garantizada,
sabiendo que Gabby está...
MK: Bueno, no solo ella estaba todavía en el hospital,
al tercer día de aquel vuelo...
Literalmente mientras yo estaba
juntándome con la estación espacial...
Dos vehículos que se mueven a 28.000 km por hora,
lo estoy piloteando, mirando por la ventana...
un montón de ordenadores...
Gabby estaba en cirugía del cerebro,
literalmente en ese mismo momento en su cirugía final
para remplazar la pieza del cráneo
que le sacaron el día que se lesionó,
con una prótesis, si, que es todo un lado de su cabeza.
Si alguno de ustedes alguna vez viene
a nuestra casa en Tucson por primera vez,
Gabby irá normalmente al congelador
y sacará el recipiente
en donde tiene el cráneo original. (Risas)
GG: El cráneo real. MK: Que a veces, asusta a la gente.
PM: ¿Eso es para el aperitivo o el postre, Mark?
MK: Bueno, eso inicia la conversación.
PM: Pero ha habido mucha conversación respecto
a algo que tú hiciste, Gabby, después del vuelo de Mark.
Tuviste que dar otro paso con valentía,
porque ahí estaba el Congreso bloqueado de nuevo,
y tú saliste del centro de rehabilitación,
fuiste a Washington,
como pudiste recorriste elrecinto de la Cámara
— casi no puedo hablar de esto sin emocionarme —
y emitiste un voto que pudo ser
el voto decisorio.
GG: El techo de la deuda. El techo de la deuda.
MK: Si, tuvimos ese voto.
Alrededor de cinco meses después de que Gabby fuera lesionada,
ella tomó la valiente decisión de volver.
Un voto muy controvertido,
pero ella quería estar allí
para hacer escuchar su voz una vez más.
PM: Y después de eso renunció
y empezó lo que ha sido una
recuperación muy lenta y difícil.
¿Cómo es ahora su vida diaria?
MK: Bueno, ese es Nelson, el perro de servicio de Gabby.
GG: Nelson.
MK: El nuevo miembro de la familia. GG: Si, si.
MK: Y lo recibimos de...
GG: Una prisión. Asesinato. MK: Tenemos muchas conexiones
con las cárceles, al parecer. (Risas)
Nelson vino de una prisión.
Había sido criado por una asesina en Massachusetts.
Pero ella hizo un muy buen trabajo con este perro.
Es un perro de servicio fantástico.
PM: Pero Gabby, ¿qué has aprendido
de tus experiencias de los últimos años?
MK: Si ¿qué has aprendido? GG: Más profundo. Más profundo.
PM: Su relación es más profunda.
Tiene que serlo. Ahora están juntos todo el tiempo.
MK: Y pienso que también el ser más apreciativos, ¿no?
GG: Agradecidos.
PM: Esta es una foto de una reunión de familia y amigos...
Me encantan estas fotos porque muestran
la relación de hoy en día de Gabby y Mark.
Y tú describes a Gabby, una y otra vez,
como más profunda en tantos niveles. ¿No es así?
MK: Pienso que cuando una tragedia pasa
en una familia, eso puede unir.
Aquí estamos mirando al transbordador espacial
volando sobre Tucson.
El transbordador Endeavour,
el mismo que yo comandé en su último vuelo,
y aquí en su último viaje sobre un avión 747
dirigido hacia Los Ángeles,
La NASA tuvo la amabilidad de hacer que volara sobre Tucson.
PM: Y por supuesto, ustedes dos
pasan por todos esos desafíos
de una recuperación lenta y difícil.
Y sin embargo, Gabby, ¿cómo haces para
mantener tu optimismo y tu actitud positiva?
GG: Quiero hacer del mundo, un lugar mejor.
(Aplausos)
PM: Y lo estás haciendo
a pesar de que tu recuperación tiene
que ser prioritaria para ustedes.
Son personas que han servido
al país y continúan haciéndolo
con una nueva iniciativa, un nuevo propósito.
Y Gabby, ¿qué hay en tu agenda ahora?
GG: "Estadounidenses por Soluciones Responsables".
MK: Nuestro comité de acción política,
con el que intentamos que los congresistas
consideren seriamente la violencia con armas de fuego en este país,
y tratamos de que
aprueben una ley razonable.
GG: Si. Si. (Aplausos)
MK: Esto nos afectó muy personalmente.
Pero no fue lo que le pasó a Gabby lo que nos movió.
Lo que de verdad nos conmovió fueron los 20 niños de primer grado
y de kinder asesinados en Newtown, Connecticut
y la reacción que vimos después...
Mira lo que ha pasado hasta ahora.
Hasta ahora la respuesta nacional ha sido
básicamente, no hacer nada.
Estamos intentando cambiar eso.
PM: Ha habido 11 tiroteos masivos
desde el de Newtown.
Una escuela cada semana en los dos primeros meses del año pasado.
¿Qué están haciendo además
de los otros esfuerzos para equilibrar
los derechos de posesión de armas con responsabilidad?
MK: Tenemos armas y las apoyamos.
Al mismo tiempo, tenemos que hacer todo lo que podamos
para mantenerlas lejos de de criminales
y de enfermos mentales peligrosos.
No es tan difícil hacer eso.
Este problema, como muchos otros,
ha llegado a ser muy polarizante y político.
Estamos tratando de equilibrar
el debate en Washington.
PM: Gracias a los dos por ese esfuerzo.
Y naturalmente, a esta valiente mujer,
con sentido de aventura,
que sigue desafiándose a ti misma,
con el cielo como límite aparente.
Tengo que compartir este vídeo
de tu aventura más reciente.
Miren a Gabby.
MK: Esto fue hace dos meses.
(Video) MK: ¿Estás bien? Lo has hecho estupendo. GG: Sí, es maravilloso. Gracias.
Bueno. Maravilloso. Ay, gracias.
Montañas. Magníficas montañas.
(Aplausos)
MK: Déjame decir que
uno de los hombres con los que Gabby saltó
ese día era un SEAL de la marina
que ella conoció en Afganistán,
que fue herido en combate y
pasó un tiempo muy duro.
Gabby lo visitó
cuando él estaba en Bethesda
y estaba atravesando un momento muy difícil.
Empezó a mejorar.
Meses más tarde, a Gabby le dispararon en la cabeza
y el la apoyó
cuando ella estaba en el hospital en Houston.
Así que tienen una conexión muy, muy especial
GG: Sí.
PM: Qué momento más hermoso.
Porque este es el escenario de TED,
Gabby, sé que trabajaste muy duro
para pensar en las ideas que querías dejarle
a esta audiencia.
GG: Gracias.
Hola a todos.
Gracias por invitarnos hoy aquí.
Ha sido un camino largo y difícil,
pero estoy mejorando.
Estoy trabajando duro,
mucha terapia; terapia de lenguaje,
fisioterapia y también yoga.
Mi espíritu es tan fuerte como siempre.
Todavía sigo luchando para hacer del mundo un lugar mejor.
Ustedes pueden hacerlo también.
Participa en tu comunidad.
Sé un líder. Da el ejemplo.
Sé apasionado. Sé valiente.
Sé lo mejor de ti. Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)
MK: Gracias. GG: Gracias.
MK: Gracias a todos. GG: Adiós (Aplausos)